okay all right so here we go the the
major headline 800 million more and
eight and more coming now which puts the
united states based on my calculation
at 3.3 roughly billion dollars
56 days into this war dana uh he also
said that uh there would be a ban on
russian ships coming into american
american ports uh this is something that
europe has already done so we are second
to that but that is a significant move
nonetheless i think the other bit of
news there is on title 42 he said
there's no decision which seemed to
suggest in the next five and a half
weeks four and a half weeks or so that
i'm
it could go either way that that's what
i take away from that answer let's see
what the cdc says yeah all right karl
rove is here he listened to the
president's speech there get your
initial reaction carl
well i'd add one more uh big item to
your list of of news items in the speech
and that is that he's going to go to
congress next week and ask for a
supplemental budget appropriation for
ukraine for not only military assistance
but also economic assistance saying that
he had
had exhausted the existing authority
voted to voted by the congress so he's
going to go back for more so i think
that was another important thing
carl the white house notwithstanding the
question about migs or jets although we
are supplying
parts for airplanes inside ukraine today
but not the physical jet that zielinski
wants not with they've been consistent
in saying
if they ask for it we give it to them
depending on the needs of the ukrainian
military
which which seems to answer the question
that we will satisfy their needs for the
day depending on where the war is
well i i mean rewind in time if you if
you thought putin was a bad man in early
february
a lot of this stuff should have been
going into ukraine then
as opposed to now in late april into may
well i look i'd go back if we're going
to be critical let's go back and be even
more critical because remember last june
before a international meeting with
putin president biden paused u.s
military assistance to ukraine and did
not begin to renew it until november so
we had june july august september
october and then beginning in
mid-november we began the resupply of
their military needs again so that's
that five month
over five month period of where we were
sitting on the sidelines it was very
problematic but having said that
we do need to give them everything they
need and and as fast as we possibly can
it's it's boggling mind-boggling to me
as to why we're laying out what we're
giving them i mean we've been telling
that you know this latest tranche of 800
million includes 155 millimeter
artillery pieces plus the president
today said we're sending 144 thousand
technic tactical rounds for every
russian tank we're sending 10 anti-tank
missile systems i mean
maybe maybe he's doing that for domestic
purposes i'm not certain it's very
useful to to do it from from the
perspective of telling the russians what
we're doing well you picked up on
something that i noticed and that was
that in many of his speeches and not
just on this topic but let's stick to
this one he'll give a laundry list of
the
statistics and the numbers and he buries
the lead you know at the end when he's
asked a question about mary opald he
says mr putin better not do that right
i'm like why don't you lead with that
where is the big overarching thing
because it does seem like we are playing
whack-a-mole after zelinski asks us for
things not getting ahead of it and not
using the full weight
of the office of the president of the
united states
i i couldn't agree more i mean look what
was missing from this what the american
people wanted and want to know and hear
from their president is why does this
matter why are we doing this why is
victory
for the ukrainians important to the
united states and if he wants to sustain
public support he's got to go explain
that and and frankly today there was a i
got a little nervous when he said
you know
our object is we don't want the russians
to take any more territory no our object
ought to be for ukrainians to win so
that the rest of the world does not
continually need to look over their
shoulder at putin moving further into
europe
by force and by uh by
by also by trying to humble his his
neighbors so yeah they put numbers in
there rather than starting with and
ending with why is this important for
america to do i'd make one other
observation from a communications
perspective and i do with so with some
trepidation because i'm on a panel with
a great presidential communicator and
that that is why why
why is it that we jam everything
together you know i think they're afraid
of you know you know he could have said
you know supplemental made it to the
purpose of today he could have said
tomorrow we're going to have a refugee
program aimed at children my sense is
they want to try and avoid talking about
ukraine so they jam everything into one
day rather than explaining it to the
american people as they as they deal
with each one of these things so
i i think they're concerned that if they
talk about ukraine too much it's not
going to allow them to talk about the
build back better agenda and universal
pre-k and the child tax credit and the
free family paid leave and blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah all of which is
going nowhere but which they think is
important for their political uh chances
against an instinct speech everything is
thrown in just one more thing he said
putin won't control all of ukraine
all of you i mean we're going to be
picky on language carl i mean that
that's a concession of sorts yeah all of
you
know
absolutely
absolutely i couldn't agree more i mean
this is why we need to say
our object is ukraine to win not to not
to sort of you know to suggest to putin
that we're willing to allow
some in that white house are undecided
on that imagine that they will be um
walking something back uh by the time
they got on the plane as he heads to
oregon today carl thank you thanks carl
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilny and i'm
ainsley earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis